i
[Música]
hola a todos y bienvenidos a esta nueva
emisión de los observadores de france 24
su red blanco como siempre un gusto
acompañarlos esta semana comenzamos en
pakistán donde la blasfemia contra el
islam es considerada un delito una
enfermera se enteró de esto
violentamente como lo van a ver en este
vídeo filmado a finales de enero en la
ciudad de karachi
esta mujer que está siendo golpeada es
una enfermera que fue atacada por sus
propios colegas en un hospital de
karachi pakistán
es cristiana y fue acusada de blasfemia
contra el profeta mahoma
un acto que es castigado con la muerte
en este país donde el islam es la
religión del estado pues
[Música]
este accidente es uno de los más de 1000
casos de blasfemia que se han registrado
en pakistán desde 1987 en muchos casos
las leyes sobre blasfemias son
utilizadas como pretexto para ajustar
cuentas especialmente contra las
minorías religiosas
el pasado noviembre por ejemplo
estallaron disturbios después de que un
hombre de la comunidad hindú fuera
acusado de haber quemado páginas del
corán david walter ex presidente de la
ong human rights focus o pakistán y cree
que las acusaciones de blasfemias se
dispararon tras la ampliación de la
legislación sobre este tema en la década
de 1980 se añadieron secciones en las
leyes paquistaníes especialmente entre
1980 y 1986 y 295 a significa profanar y
formar la religión y la 295 b significa
profanar o difamar a el corán
y la 295 ce se refiere a los comentarios
desagradables contra el profeta mahoma
estas penas van desde el encarcelamiento
a la cadena perpetua hasta la pena de
muerte
pero no hay un solo caso de ejecución de
una persona a través del sistema
judicial
porque a menudo estas acusaciones son
falsas y estos problemas provienen de
rencores y conflictos personales aunque
algunas minorías como los cristianos o
los hindúes son atacados de forma
desproporcionada en los casos de
blasfemia los acusados suelen ser
incluso musulmanes en este caso por
ejemplo el pasado mes de marzo una turba
asaltó una fábrica de ropa en karachi
intentando linchar a un musulmán que
supuestamente había profanado a un
ejemplar del corán
la víctima que finalmente sobrevivió
negó las acusaciones
igualmente dio muy bien vos quieras
cuando se acuse a un musulmán solo se
acusa al individuo nunca se ataca a la
comunidad ni a su familia pero por el
contrario cuando se acusa a una minoría
no solo se ataca al individuo sino
también a su familia ya toda su
comunidad y a veces incluso a las
iglesias y templos los acusados de
blasfemia en pakistán se enfrentan a un
peligro constante sobre todo el de las
ejecuciones extrajudiciales según las
últimas noticias la enfermera agredida
por sus compañeros a finales de enero
vive desde entonces escondida con su
familia
vamos a eeuu donde le vamos a mostrar un
proyecto que combina el activismo y la
gastronomía
hace un año paralelamente al movimiento
black light matters un estadounidense
lanzó su propia plataforma llamada black
friday para animar a los internautas a
apoyar a los negocios afroamericanos
durante la pandemia de kobin 19
que vengan a mí y soy que jay carney
vivo en charleston carolina del sur en
el 5 de abril de 2020 cree una
plataforma llamada black friday black
friday viernes de comida negra es una
oportunidad para que todos apoyen un
negocio de dueños afroamericanos un día
a la semana
comencé blackfoot friday's en la
primavera en el despertar mundial acerca
del movimiento black lights matters
empezó ese verano luchamos por la misma
causa pero lo hacemos de forma diferente
creo que los black friday se
beneficiaron de ello porque tuve una
gran ola de suscriptores hasta el 31 de
mayo solo tenía mil suscriptores
a finales de junio tenía 4200
público hechos en los que enseñó en 60
segundos la historia negra de estados
unidos a través del lente de la comida y
la cocina
job hice un vídeo sobre un señor que
inventó el camión refrigerado otro vídeo
sobre un señor al que se le atribuye la
creación del helado de fresa un hombre
negro
he hecho vídeos sobre el jack daniel's y
el whisky bourbon aun con mi rest han
oído hablar de aun con y rest
en resumen aunque angers es el apodo de
un esclavo que le enseño a jack daniel's
a hacer whisky en tennessee es
importante señalar que gran parte de la
cocina estadounidense viene de la gente
de color of code
en mi zona no solo hay un reconocimiento
oficial del arroz rojo y su sabor sino
también de cómo llegó a eeuu y los que
fueron brutalmente secuestrados en
áfrica occidental por sus habilidades en
el cultivo del arroz todos hablaban
lenguas diferentes todos tenían
tradiciones diferentes pero todos ellos
fueron capaces de reunirse y recrear lo
que ahora conocemos en eeuu como arroz
robo
y de esta manera llegamos al final de
nuestro programa por esta semana
recuerde que todos nuestros contactos
aparecen en pantalla donde esperamos sus
fotos y videos para seguir contando las
historias del lado de la gente
[Música]